All right morty go talk about the thing they paid
us a lot okay yeah uh this is the playstation 5.
it's really fast yeah yeah they really wanted you
to mention the speed that was really important
yeah it's super fast like way less of those long
loading screens you know how do you tell them the
thing about the buttons huh oh the controller has
haptic feedback vibrations that simulate in-game
actions the l2 and r2 buttons have adaptive
resistance don't block the console they wanted
that in the shot oh yeah man rick this commercial
is kind of boring you know it's like the
playstation 5 is pretty cool all right we're done
go play ps5 oh god i'm a clone you're not a clone
for a while we were content to not know whether
she was or wasn't and who is that uh a clone i
always felt like yeah she's a clone which means
that there's a beth out there let's meet her honey
you're back you seem surprised you never wrote
and never exploded and then he proceeds to lie
to both his home daughter and his space daughter
about which one is cloned he told me you're the
clone what do you think he told me if one of
you is still alive you're my real daughter if
you're both alive don't hurt the other one she's
just a clone she's not worth it i'm coming baby
i wanted a version of beth that was more like rick
and therefore ironically hated rick i came back to
kill him you know i'd like to help which beth
is real and which beth is a clone you jerk-offs
ready to get the answers to your burning questions
you know what happened there that night i want you
to decide that's turned around and locked eyes
with him and said tell me what kind of daughter
you would like me to be rick's response was to
roofie her and avoid the entire conversation
which is an ancient greek level of bad fatherhood
and then you can't bear to even know which one is
which big money big money which is i think the
most cowardly part of it all you literally don't
even know which of your daughters is real
of course you don't he made a non-choice
and committed to it really hard yeah absolutely
yeah you get no answers but and in effect i mean
hopefully that's not a dissatisfying thing because
the answer is one or the other the the core of it
is finding beth some solace with that and i think
the only solace she can find is in there's none
and being okay with that i don't care
what's in that vial yeah me neither do
you love having two moms and i love having two
wives isn't the more important fact that they
both exist and the reason why they
both exist yeah your pieces either way
are you tired of your butter being so
far away hey what's up i'm rick z17
the citadel of rick's gift shop rick it's a big
mouthful come on down to the citadel rick's gift
shop where you can enter to win a real life butter
robots it's powered by wendy's wendy's breakfast
you hear what i just said it's an actual moving
talking butter robot that will fetch you butter
and it'll watch you eat a wendy's honey butter
chicken biscuit while it has an existential
breakdown here let me turn it over to wendy's
rick hey what's up i'm wendy's rick i i gotta
tell you i love that wendy's breakfast it's really
good and i also love the citadel bricks gift shop
i also love that we managed to put this together
baby managed to put all this all the moving parts
together wendy's and the citadel bricks together
and we're back over to you uh citadel rick thanks
on citadel rick z17 uh so yeah enter to win the
butter robot in the gift shop giveaway powered by
wendy's breakfast it's an actual diegetic thing
that is plucked from the universe of the show
and and it's real and you could win it butter
robots hurry powered by wendy's breakfast you
got to get in there you got to sign up and
win do it do it now do it now get in there
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this is going
to be my new rick and morty season five teaser
trailer they just had a big adult swim festival
with a rick and morty panel they were talking
about rick and morty season five episodes they're
even working on rick and morty season seven
episodes right now too so i'll explain what they
said and what's coming up if you're brand new to
the channel be sure to subscribe to get all the
videos i will be doing episode videos for all
the rick and morty season 5 episodes when they
release and i'll talk about the release date too
we'll do a new amazon giveaway all you have to
do to enter is be a subscriber and leave all
your predictions for season 5 on the video so
we'll talk about the footage then i'll explain
everything that they said about season 5 episodes
on the panel they start with the rick and morty
playstation 5 ad rick selling them out again like
he does in all their ads if you've ever watched
any of the other rick and morty commercials that
they make for the show rick is always selling them
out sometimes you can see him counting his money
while morty is complaining about selling them out
but because the ps5 the xbox series x just
came out they're doing commercials for that
i actually have both of them i don't have any big
complaints there are a couple minor bugs with both
of the consoles that you've probably been reading
about but that's to be expected with the launch of
a new console generation for the most part they do
exactly what they say like morty is joking about
the loading time way faster in all the special
features that the actual controller has those are
all true they're actually pretty fantastic but the
butter robot ad is an actual thing for merch that
they'll be selling in the citadel bricks gift shop
that's an actual thing that they created in real
life i think it'll be available to purchase before
rick and morty season 5 episodes are released but
the butter robot is an actual small robot and
it's really expensive so it's not something that
you could just go out and spend five bucks
on maybe when we get closer to the episodes
being released i'll actually do a giveaway for
some of them depending on how many they wind up
selling i don't think it's a limited thing i think
they'll just be selling as many as they can make
buckle up get ready the last big rick and morty
season 5 trailer they released was that season
five episode cold open with mr nimbus it was
basically their marvel namor parody it was just an
animatic but the way it feels is just like they're
cold opens and usually those don't have anything
to do with the plots of actual episodes they
just end up being funny one-off adventures like
this crazy thing happen but then something happens
and they go off to the plot of the actual episode
this is just rick and morty escaping from
a planet during an adventure that's gone
really really wrong and it seems like reality is
shattered and they're looking through the scenes
of many different dimensions in previous episodes
like there's a marvel blade rick in morty which
just seems badass this is obviously wesley snipes
blade that they're parodying here but marvel is
actually getting ready to release a brand new
blade movie with mahershala ali during marvel
phase 5. i'll talk about that during my marvel
videos because it's going to be a while before
they make that movie but if you zoom in enhance
here they just have many different really wtf
versions of rick and morty like morty cradling
baby rick woodcutter lumberjack rick cool morty
they go back to earth thinking they're going
to crash and die and it turns into this whole
jessica morty thing with him wanting to have
last words with her then it turns into a whole
name or aquaman joke with mr nimbus who seems
like he's been rick's nemesis this whole time
that we've just found out about now big news
flash apparently rick is never supposed to go
near the ocean that's canon now but one of the
biggest things they revealed during the recent
rick and morty season 5 panel is that they're
doing way more with the space version of beth
remember they have the clone beth they have
the space beth now who's kind of like the
cool aunt that comes and visits every once in
a while the way that dan harmon talks about her
they didn't say how many episodes she's going to
appear in during season five but if you remember
how she was such a huge part of the rick and morty
season four finale i would imagine they dedicate
another entire episode to her where just some
of the family goes off on an adventure with her
the whole thing with her is that she actually
just proves the theory that there could be a
citadel of bests out there the beth that decided
to embrace her heritage and become more like rick
they teased a little bit during season three
when they had that conversation about the clone
he says you basically have as much potential as me
and he's supposed to be the smartest person in the
multiverse meaning theoretically that beth could
also become one of the smartest people in the
multiverse or a version of beth could but the way
they talk about space beth it sounds like they're
not going to get crazy with any kind of citadel
best twist anytime soon it'll just be the space
version of beth coming back in episodes but they
did tease the idea that there could be an infinite
beth storyline out there in future seasons harmon
also said that there's going to be some moments
where rick and jerry actually become friends
joking that the show is jumping the shark because
that seems like a break in the fundamental dynamic
of their relationship they said it's all about the
concept of friends that you're super disrespectful
to in a furtherance of the dynamic at the end of
season 3 with the whirly dirly conspiracy where
they call a little bit of a truce they find
some common ground for just a hot minute before
they go back to the regular dynamic the way they
talk about summer during season five is as she
continues to become more of a competitor to morty
in the adventure market how she's able to connect
with rick on a very different level than morty is
like you remember the devil episode they have
a very different dynamic than rick and morty do
even though rick and morty is the main dynamic
of the show right now as we're speaking though
they're actually finishing the writing for rick
and morty season seven episodes if you remember
around comic-con last summer they were starting
on rick and morty season six so that gives you an
idea for how quickly they're blowing through the
writing of the episodes is really the animation
that takes a long long time for them to complete
for those of you asking why there was actually
a rick and morty season 4 trailer a while ago
that they released just for the animation itself
where the animators talk about how it's so much
more complex than other shows like south park
they can turn an episode around inside a week but
just in terms of rick and morty season 5 release
date right now it seems like they're planning on
a spring release date and they should be able to
release all 10 episodes but even if they do break
it into half the way that they're so far ahead
like they're working on rick and morty season
seven right now before they've aired season five
even if they split the episodes into two blocks of
five episodes they'll still be able to release one
full season every single year for the remainder
of all the episodes they were renewed for
remember a couple years ago they basically got
renewed through what will be rick and morty season
10 because they're doing 10 episodes per season so
it'll be a long time before we start hearing news
about what's going on during rick and morty season
10 and obviously many years before they wind up
dropping those episodes but that doesn't mean that
that's the end of the show they could always be
renewed for more episodes after that they could
always wind up doing a rick and morty movie dan
harmon is still talking about doing that community
movie but what'll happen is i'll just keep doing
more rick and morty season 5 trailer videos and
teasers and easter eggs as they release more
footage and details in the next few months adult
swim usually waits until they get within about a
month of episodes dropping to start releasing a
bunch of new footage but they always give away
big details before then and the cast and crew dan
harmon always talk about what's going on so post
all your theories about rick and morty season 5
and leave all your video requests in the comments
below i've got a couple new mandalorian marvel
and dc videos that i'll be posting this week
my full mandalorian season 2 episode 5 video for
ahsoka tano will be this friday just like normal
well you wait for all that click here for my
brand new mandalorian season 2 ahsoka tano video
and click here for that other brand
new rick and morty season 5 trailer
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe i'll see you guys tonight!